شفافيه في نقاط فقد تعرفت على اولويات
المكتب
وحدها عام 2011
والنائب المدعي العام مسؤول عن ذلك
وهنالك الهجره القسريه والاتجار بالبشر
وهنالك اعتقالات او في مخيمات وبعض
الاتهامات الاخرى التي نحقق فيها تحققنا
بعض النجاحات
طريقه تحقيقات المشتركه التي تحدثت عنه
قبل قليل واننا جمال هذا الفريق في سبتمبر
والعمل مستمر
او من اثيوبيا الى المحاكمه هولاندا
ومحاكمه ايطاليا
وكان لاعبين الاساسيين ليس فقط
العبوديه الجنسيه
عليها ونعمل مع شركات وادركنا بنا كل هذه
القضايا قد لا تبرز امام محكمه الجنائيه
وليس هنالك حاجه لذلك ولكنها يجب ان تحصل
الى محكمه ما سواء في اوروبا او ليبيا او
اي مكان اخر يجب ان نقف من اجل تحقيق
العداله ويجب ان يكون موحدين لكن نحافظ
على سلامتهم وسلامه الشقائنا وشقيقاتنا
وكما قلت هذه المشكله ليست مشكله طرف اخر
هي مشكله نحن
يجب ان نكون مستقبل وحتى اذا ما عملنا
جاهدين على ذلك
محطه في زيارهكم
بصراحه عن صدمتك
اكثر في هذا الموضوع تحديدا
بوديا
والوفاه والجمارك في سراليون ولايبيريا
والبلقانه ورواندا او حتى ثلاثه عوامل في
بغداد وسفر الى الموصل وسنجان وشاهت
المقابره الجماعيه لداعش ولكن ترهون اظهرت
لنا
الدرجات الحرمان العاليه
البشر
اطفال بعض الاشخاص ابناءهم واباءهم في
ظروف مروعه جدا همم
الاوضاع مرعبه
التخلص منها وكانها النفايات